so it looks like some projects that a
lot of people thought might have been
cancelled we've even heard some rumors
that they were cancelled aren't
cancelled and it looks like Marvel
Studios has some pretty specific plans
for them but most importantly the
characters that Marvel Studios has plans
for are characters that we really really
care about and are characters that we
have wanted to make their MCU debut for
some time now we are talking about Nova
and Ghost Rider and we'll also be
talking about Vision Quest and the
Silver Surfer what's what going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and I'm happy
to say that we've gotten a new report
stating that these characters we thought
might not come are indeed still coming
Marvel Studio still has plans for them
to make their MCU debuts this is also
coming with the news that Marvel studio
is now implementing a new content
strategy for Disney plus we did a video
about this yesterday describing the new
content strategy for Marvel and
explaining what it means for the future
of the MCU but basically Marvel Studios
has introduced a new category called
Marvel Spotlight which will basically be
oneoff stories in the MCU about
characters who you don't really need to
see any other projects previously in the
MCU to understand the story of the
current project Ekko is the first
project to get the Marvel Spotlight
Banner on it which means you can go into
Echo blind you don't have to see
anything prior including Hawkeye which
she was in Marvel Studios has expressed
that these are oneoff comic stories
which you can watch casually it's a
casual viewing experience you don't have
to worry about what came before or what
came after just enjoy the story as it is
and according to some insiders more
heroes are going to fall under this
category Heroes that we are really
looking forward to like Nova and Ghost
Rider so let's dive into what Marvel
Studios has planned and a big reminder
if you subscribe and leave a comment you
are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month also I'm still
sick so pardon my voice so with the
introduction of the category of Marvel
Spotlight a lot of people have been
wondering which projects exactly are
going to fall under this category and
specifically who is going to fall under
this category which Marvel characters
are we going to get series about that
are essentially going to be oneoff
stories well let me first clarify that
just because something may debut under
the Marvel Spotlight category does not
mean that in the future it won't have an
impact so if a character debuts under a
Marvel Spotlight like the Silver Surfer
just because it's a oneof story that you
don't need to know what's happened in
the MCU in the past to watch and enjoy
that doesn't mean that this character
won't go on in the future to connect
with another MCU project or appear in
one like the Silver Surfer appearing in
the Fantastic 4 film Ekko is the perfect
example and a great debut for Marvel
Spotlight because the story itself
you're not going to need to know what's
happened in the past in the MCU however
we already know that this show overall
does connect to the larger MCU because
Daredevil is going to be an echo Kingpin
is an echo as well well and both are
going to appear in the Daredevil series
obviously Daredevil is appearing and
kingpin's going to be the main villain
as well so just because the specific
story we'll be watching in the Echo
series is a secluded oneoff grounded
story it doesn't mean that we won't see
connections to the MCU however these
stories are just going to be very
grounded and secluded and again you
don't need to know what is going on in
the entire MCU to focus on this one
story the account Scarlet Witch updates
said this in a tweet
Marvel Studios introduces Marvel
Spotlight Banner Spotlight gives us a
platform to bring more grounded
character-driven stories to the screen
our audience doesn't need to have seen
other Marvel series to understand what's
happening and that is by Brad wbom
executive producer at Marvel Studios but
then they ask what projects would you
like to see and Alex P from the cosmic
circus has confirmed in a reply to this
tweet Nova and Ghost Rider definitely go
here now we've had reports in the past
that Nova and Ghost Rider were both
supposed to get their own special
presentations from Disney plus this was
going to be a way to introduce these
characters before they go on to appear
in other MCU projects kind of giving
them their own Spotlight so it looks
like Marvel Studios might kind of be
shifting away from special presentations
to Marvel Spotlight projects which are
kind of going to be the same thing with
the exception that now under Marvel
Spotlight you don't need to know what
happened anywhere else before in the MCU
take for example the Guardians of the G
galy holiday special presentation for
that you definitely had to know who the
Guardians of the Galaxy were what their
relationship was before you had to watch
Guardians too to know mantis you had to
know the relationship between all of the
Guardians plus you had to know the Kevin
Bacon big reference for Peter Quill so
we're probably still going to continue
to get special presentations for movies
and shows like that but these Marvel
Spotlight Banner projects are going to
be perfect for introducing new
characters who have great stories of
their own who can don't have to but can
go on to be involved in these bigger
projects for example Nova should
definitely go on to be a part of the
Guardians of the Galaxy or even just go
on to be his own hero and team up with
some other Heroes perhaps in an Avengers
film later on in the future maybe King
Dynasty maybe Secret Wars same thing
with Ghost Rider and I'm really glad
that they are still planning on making
the Nova and Ghost Rider special
presentation slm Marvel Studios Banner
projects because I was really excited
for both characters but Ghost Rider is a
specific character that can have his own
story kind of do his origin story but
then have him appear in another film
that is not necessarily his own film for
example if they decided to do a midnight
Suns project or they decided to put him
in maybe blade or another Supernatural
Project we would have already gotten his
origin story to where we wouldn't need
it in that film The Silver Surfer is
another one that the cosmic circus
reported some time ago that was supposed
to get its own special presentation to
introduce the Silver Surfer ahead of the
Fantastic 4 and although Alex P does
state that Nova and Ghost Rider are
definitely coming under the Marvel
Spotlight Banner we haven't really heard
much recently about the Silver Surfer
special presentation so unfortunately
we're not sure if that is still
happening at this moment but Nova and
Ghost Rider are and speaking of projects
that we didn't know if they were
canceled or not it looks like Vision
Quest is not canceled Joanna Robinson
one of the authors of MCU the reign of
Marvel Studio stated that it's all but
canceled however when these reports came
out some people like Alex Perez and my
time to shine hello did dispute this
fact and that these projects were still
in the works Wonderman was another
project mentioned but we don't have an
update for that at this point in time
however yesterday my time to shine hello
came out and stated they are still
working on Vision Quest not cancelled
which is great news because this project
was supposed to be very important to the
future of the MCU this project was
supposedly and reportedly going to set
up the Children's Crusade which
essentially was going to be a Young
Avengers project simply not titled the
Young Avengers however it has been said
that the Marvel's is also supposed to
set up a Young Avengers project as well
so it would make sense that Vision Quest
has not been cancelled plus Marvel
Studios did tease us with spectral
Vision or white Vision in the finale of
w division he just took off went away
and we have not heard anything about him
yet we do know that in Vision Quest he's
supposed to get his own family like he
does in the comics and we also hope that
eventually down the line the Scarlet
Witch will somehow be reunited with
spectral Vision who should have all of
his memories thanks to the other Vision
that Wanda created for herself in
Westview but this vision is real and if
he has all of the memories that the
original one had then in theory Wanda
and this spectral Vision should be able
to get together and be pretty much the
same as it was before granted this
Vision establishes an emotional
connection with Wanda as well so it's
good news that this isn't canceled it's
great news that Nova and Ghost Rider are
still coming to the MCU we're super
excited about that but let us know all
of your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof